Here's a voicemail that came in.
Our voicemail number is a two one nine two
David P. A voicemail about mask orders.
Let's take a listen to it, David.
I wanted to see what your thoughts were with
mandatory mask orders just in general.
A few cities have started enacting.
And I was curious if we should see that at
the state level and what kind of punishments
should be levied assuming people violated
them.
Thanks.
OK, so.
First, let's talk about the legal basis.
There is a legal basis for MASC orders.
No question about it.
Remember that whole states rights, power of
the states thing that a lot of Republicans
like to talk about, this falls under that
a federal nationwide masc order from the federal
government would actually be legally dubious.
State and local governments have pretty broad
authority, particularly during a public health
emergency.
So I believe that the legal case for a statewide
or citywide mass Schauder is not legally problematic
inside of businesses, businesses.
Remember, Republicans wanted this stuff.
Businesses have broad authority within their
businesses and they can also say you've got
to wear a mask to be in my business.
But I feel like it's the wrong focus.
The reality is, I don't think this should
come down to legality.
It comes down to a legal question because
so many people just don't want to wear a mask.
We know they're very, very effective.
What this should come down to is doing the
right thing because we want to fix this and
we want to take care of the people around
us and we want to take care of our communities.
So if you make this a legal argument, I believe
that states, cities and states are very, very
comfortably able to legally put in place mask
orders.
I hate that it's even a question we should
be doing it because it's just the right thing
to do.
We've got a great bonus show today.
We will talk about what was a closer than
expected race in the Kentucky Republican Senate.
Amy McGrath officially winning against Charles
Booker.
We will talk about that.
We will talk about the South Pole warming
at three times the global average over the
last 30 years.
Horrifying stuff.
And we will also discuss Mississippi dropping
its Confederate themed flag.
All of those stories and more on the bonus
show.
Don't miss it.
He become a member at Doyne Pacman dot com
to get instant access.